royal correspondent rauner Mills reports
now from Auckland it's not the first
thing you expect to do as a member of
the royal family but if welly wagging is
what the locals want you to do you give
it a go
mekin has made a big impression on this
tour the mixed-race heritage and
commitment to gender equality helping to
reach a new audience and welcomed by New
Zealand's Prime Minister particularly
New Zealand 125 years women have had the
vote but there are still things that we
need to do around things like domestic
violence and pay equity so having role
models from around the world like
herself standing up and making
statements around just fairness and
equality I think is really powerful we
sat down with governor-general Patsy
Reddy
the Queen's representative in New
Zealand who's been struck by Megan's
ability to connect it's so much easier
to talk about diversity when you are the
embodiment of diversity and so she is
showing that a person of color a person
of mixed race background heritage can
achieve whatever she wants and that's a
great model for New Zealand in Auckland
the final City of their tour another
mainly female and young crowd had turned
out to see them
[Music]
it has been striking that since they got
engaged and throughout their wedding
preparations Megan who champions
diversity has talked about how she
really wanted to connect with the
Commonwealth but it is an institution
that some people see as an outdated
talking shop and a modern-day
manifestation of the British Empire for
Maori groups here it's less about the
Commonwealth or the crown their fight is
against politicians over issues like
land rights they're divided over whether
Megan can help highlight their cause
megan is actually you know engaging with
groups people listening to those stories
and actually hearing and seeing the fix
of it and projecting it out and sharing
it with other people through her roles
and I think that can bring about change
follow them lol Lily bula vinaka
[ __ ] a loafer lahia to Kiana tena koutou
katoa
Harry was made a youth ambassador to the
Commonwealth earlier this year
Megan is happy to share that work for
those who want to revamp the image of
the Commonwealth it would be difficult
to find a better team Riano Mills Sky
News in Auckland
[Music]